un titre anglais pour une exposition sur
le cinéma screenplay ou comment jouer
avec l'écran un questionnement ludique
sur le rapport au cinéma l'expérience du
spectateur aussi c'est ce qui
m'intéressait dans cette exposition là
avec toujours un souci de diversité des
champs et des pratiques artistiques et
forcément une prédominance pour l'art
vidéo puisqu'on parle de cinéma on parle
d'image en mouvement mais on a aussi du
dessin on a aussi des maquettes des
objets on a également de la photographie
on a des pièces sonores des
installations 11 artistes internationaux
voient leur création mise en lumière
dans la salle d'exposition de Guy encour
parmi les œuvres une fresque géante
réalisée spécialement par la
plasticienne Julie Dumont elle a réalisé
pour cette exposition là une grande
fresque euh storyboardé de 4 m par 2,50
de hauteur où donc elle a elle elle a
passé une semaine à guuille en cours
pour réaliser cette pièce qui va ensuite
intégrer le fond d'œuvre de la ville un
travail sur cré spontané l'artiste s'est
laissé guider par l'inspiration qui lui
venait en regardant des films des
références cinématographiques incarnées
par des dialogues des dessins des
répliques pour appeler James Bond retour
vers le futur ou encore
Terminator l'exposition loin d'être
réservée au cinéphil s'adresse à tous
les publics elle parle de cinéma mais de
façon assez générale et avec des
références qui peuvent parler à tous
c'est-à-dire qu'on va effectivement
parler d'itchcock mais on va aussi
parler de Twilight ça fait des des
allers-retours en tout cas des écarts de
référence dans le cinéma qui nous
intéresse aussi parce que justement le
cinéma est peut-être un des champs
artistiques qui cloisonne le moins
l'exposition screenplay s'étend hors de
la salle pour investir une partie de la
bibliothèque universitaire à guillancour
la plasticienne Julie Dumont y présente
des œuvres autour de la figure du héros
dans le
cinéma